우리나라에서 제일 비싼 파출소가
공매로 나왔습니다. 그래서 그 공매의
금액이 무려 121억에 여러분들
파출소가 121억에 나왔습니다. 제가
한번 직접 현장 가서 과연 어떤 파출
속길래 121억이나 되는지 어
여러분들한테 한번 좀 소개해 드리도록
하겠습니다. 가시죠
님 위치가 어딜까요? 어, 여기
파출수 위치는 그 서울시 강남구
청담동이 있습니다. 그래서 우리
나라에서 가장 좋은 동네에 위치하고
있고 그 청담 여기서 그렇게 거리가
멀지가 않아요. 네. 그래서 거의
역세권이라고 불릴 정도로 되게 가까운
위치에 있고 거기다가 코너 땅입니다.
그래서 가시성도 되게 뛰어나긴 하지만
땅의 명적이 굉장히 작아요. 그래서
땅의 면적이 몇 평이냐면 몇 평
같으세요? 121억이면
>> 121억이면
한 70평, 80평
>> 무려 49평입니다.
굉장히 작아요. 49평인데
121억이면 돼지 평단가 한 거의 약
한 2억 5천 정도 되거든요.
>> 와 그 정도로 상당히 가격이
비쌉니다. 물론 이제 거기 우측에
최근에 팔렸던게 한 2억 5천에 팔린
사례가 있긴 한데 그거 치고도 가격이
좀 너무 비싸고 그 무엇보다 딱
면적이 너무 작아요. 네. 위치가
좋은 건가요?
>> 위치는 좋습니다. 근데 지금 저기
보시면 저거든요.
한번 봐 보세요.
저기 보이시나요?
>> 아, 위치가 되게 좋네.
>> 그렇죠. 그래서 여기가 이제 대로변
코너고 저쪽으로 가면 이제 청담 여기
있습니다.
[음악]
그래서 지금 봐 보세요. 지금 건물
상태를 보면 그 1975년도에
지었습니다. 그래서 그때 딱 강남 막
개발될 때 이제 지었던 그런 건물이고
지금 보시면은 건물이 매우 노후화돼
있어요. 그리고이 건물이 보면은이
땅이 그렇게 반듯한 땅은 아닌 거
같아요. 약간 피자 조각처럼 돼
있습니다. 그래서 지금 보시면 요렇게
>> 뭔가
빠진 오래된 거 같은데 오랫동안 비어
있다 오랫동안 비어 있었어요. 그래서
저기 청단공원으로 이전한 다음에
여기는 좀 오랫동안 비어 있었습니다.
파출소가 아이러니하게도 위치가 되게
좋은 데가 많아요. 그래서 지금 여기
청남동뿐만 아니라 신사동에도 도산대로
있고 그리고 기존에 원래 삼성동에도
그 봉운사로 대로변에 있어요. 그래서
지금 파주소들이 다 노른잔 땅에
있더라고요. 그래서 공매 진행할 때
되게 좀 비싸게 어 이렇게 공매
진행하는 경우 많습니다. 투자를
잘했어요 나라가. 그래서 지금 삼성동
것도 제가 알고 있기로는 그때 공매
시작가가 거의 한 80억, 86억
막이 정도였던 걸로 기억하는데 그것도
아마 낙찰된 걸로 알고 있습니다.
그래서 지금 이거 같은 경우에도
위치가 굉장히 좋기 때문에 어
121억에 진행 중인데 근데 지금
앞서 보신 것처럼 땅의 모양이 그렇게
이쁘지가 않아서 건물을 지었을 때
이렇게 날리는 면적이 되게 많을
것으로 예상이 됩니다. 그리고 돼지
면적이 한 49평이 정도밖에 안 돼서
여기가 3종이거든요. 이제 3삼종은
건폐율이 50%기 때문에 한개층
면적이 한 20평대 중반 그리고
실평수는 아마 한 10열평대 후반
정도밖에 안 나와서 좀 건물을
짓기에도 좀 애매한 면적이지 않나
이렇게 생각을 합니다.
>> 121억이면은
>> 좀 싼 편인가요?
>> 어 여기 사실 시세긴 해요. 그러니까
저기 옆에 건물이 저기 보이죠?
저 성모치가 들어가 있는 저게
170억에 팔렸거든요. 그래서 저게
한 대지평당 한 2억 5천 정도의
매각이 됐습니다. 그거와 대비해서는
한 시세 정도에 나와 있긴 한데 한번
또 유찰이 될 거 같은 느낌인데 한번
지켜봐야 될 거 같아요. 그래서 다음
주에 공매 진행 예정이고요.
>> 안 팔리면은 계속 가격이 떨어지니까네
>> 네. 네. 계속 가격이 떨어져요.
그래서 보시면 이게 지금 땅 모양이
피자 조각처럼 생겼어요. 어, 이렇게
저기 역건물은 돼지가 한 60평대
정도 되고 그다음에 면적이 그래도
조금 있습니다. 한 123평인 가기
정도 되는데 여기는 건물 무조건
지어야 돼요. 차 조심하. 그래서 뭘
하기에는 조금 면적이 애매한 부분이
있는 거 같습니다. 근데 여기가
청담동 8번즈예요. 주소가 너무
좋습니다.이 건물을 푸실 수도
있겠네요.
>> 무조건 부셔서 지어야죠. 그러니까
지금 상태로 쓰기에는 좀 애매하고
수익성이 안 나옵니다. 121억
투자해서
>> 뭐 리모델링할 가능성은 없을까요?
리모델링 해서 쓰기에는 뭔가 임대료도
안 나오고 뭐 직접 운영하실 분이 난
해가지고 직접 쓰고 싶다라고 하면
모르겠는데 이거 뭐 사업성이 안 나올
것 같습니다. 땅 면적도 너무 작아
가지고
>> 주차 부지는 요렇게 나올 수가 있
>> 어 예컨인데 일단 이쪽으로 다 빼야
될 거 같아요. 건물을 대로변 쪽으로
그리고 이쪽 뒤쪽으로 이제 주차장을
만들어야 될 거 같은데 아 뭔가
설계하기가 좀 쉽지 않은 땅이긴
합니다.
>> 대표님이 보셨을 때 121억의
메리트가 있는 건물이라고 생각을
하시나요? 어, 저는 뭐 위치나 이런
거는 너무 좋기는 한데 땅 면적도 좀
그렇고 그 가격 치고는 조금 생각해
볼 거 같습니다. 저는 오히려 좀
면적이 좀 더 큰 거를 찾아볼 거
같아. 물론 이제 위치나 이런 건
너무 좋은데
>> 지금이 건물이 공매라고 알고 있는데
왜 공매인가요,이 건물이? 그러니까
어떻게 보면 이게 나라 땅이거든요.
그래서 나라 땅을 팔 때는 이제
공매를 공매 절차를 좀 진행해요.
그래서 온비드 사이트를 통해서 확인할
수 있습니다. 경매 같은 경우에는
이제 개인 자산이라든지 이런 거를
진행하는데 지금 요거 같은 경우에는
나라땅이기 때문에 공매 절차를 통해서
입찰 방식으로 어 진행한다라고 보시면
될 거 같아요. 그리고 여기 입질을
좀 더 덧붙여서 설명드리면 여기 그
앞에가 청담 4거리예요. 청담
4거리고 그다음에 여기까지가 이제 뭐
미용실 여기 이제 준노 준노 4억도
있고 어 이제 미용실이라든지
가구점이라든지
뭐 이런 옷가게라든지 그리고 이제 뭐
피부가라든지 이런데도 좀 많이 들어와
있어요. 그래서 명품 그런 거리랑은
상권이 좀 다르다라고 보셔야 될 거
같아요.
>> 근데 명품 거리랑 그렇게 거리 차이가
안 나는 걸로 알고 있는데네
>> 아예 다른 곳이라고 보면 됩니다.
그래서 도로가 여기 도산대로가 거의
50m 정도 되는데 그렇게 안
넘어가요, 사람들이. 예, 상권은
원래 엄청 안 좋았다가 최근에 조금
차고 있긴 하는데 뭐 아직까지 그래도
비어 있는데도 좀 있고 상권 차이도
되게 큽니다.
>> 여기에 만약에 들어온다면
>> 네.
>> 대표님 생각은 어떤게 들어올 것
같으세요?
병원하기에 면적이 너무 작고 그래서
뭐 웨딩 관련 업체나 그런 뭐 가구
같은 거 통으로 들어올 만한 어 그런
업체들이 들어올 거 같은데 일단은 뭐
수지 타산에 안 맞을 것 같아서
121억에 사서 건물을 짓는다라고
쳤을 때 거의 한 뭐 뭐 예를 들어서
뭐 100평 뭐 한 초중간 정도
짓는다라고 쳐도 거의 신축비가 뭐 한
15억 20억 들 거 같거든요.
그러면은 뭐 취득세랑 이런 거
감안하면은 뭐 140억 150억이
정도인데 요즘에 이제 용적률이 조금
상행해 주긴 했지만 만약 그렇게
되더라도 이게 주차대수 다 빼야
되거든요. 그리고 건물 또 높게
올리면은 신축비도 워낙 또 많이
들어서 건물 연면적이 뭐 한 100
뭐 100평 한 초중간 정도 된다라고
쳤을 때 임대료를 만약에 그 정도
투자했을 때 최소 한 뭐 3, 4천
이상은 나와야 되거든요. 근데 그
정도로
뭔가 들어오긴 쉽진 않을 것
같습니다. 면적이 좀 애매하긴
해가지고. 그리고 여러분들이 또
아셔야 될게 제가 알고 있기로 한
20m가 25m 정도에 있는 대로변에
있는 건물들은 일조건 사선을 받지
않습니다. 네. 그래서 건물은 좀
반듯하게 올라갈 거 같은데 올라간다
하더라도이 돼지가 워낙 작기 때문에
한개층 바닥 면적이 뭐 20평 초중반
정도고 그 실평수는 뭐 10평
후반대라고 하면은 뭔가 들어올 만한
업종이 좀 괜찮은게 있을까라고 생각해
보면 좀 마땅치 않은 거 같습니다.
여기 건너편에 그 한국 근거래소가
들어와 있는데 임대료를 정확히
말씀드릴 수는 없지만 요거랑 접목해서
봤을 때 이거 건물 다 지으면 제가
봤을 때 한 진짜 3천 정도 나와도
진짜 잘 나온다라고 생각하거든요.
만약에 140억 150억 투자해서
월세에 3천 정도라고 하면 수익
율류를 한번 계산해 보자.
3천 정도라고 쳤을 때 어 수익률이
막 2% 건물 다 짓고 나서도 그래서
3천도 일단 쉽지 않은데 그래서 좀
수익성이 안 나오는 거 같아요.
>> 투자 대비 뽑으려면 작전가가 어느
정도
>> 뭐 한 80억이 정도까진 내려가야지
될 거 같은데 지켜봐야 될 거 이번에
진짜 낙찰되면 제가 한번
지켜보겠습니다. 어떻게 바뀔지.
어떤게 들어올지도 궁금하네요.
>> 근데 또 위치는 워낙 좋기 때문에 뭐
제가 생각했던 거보다 더 비싸게 팔릴
수도 있고 뭐 더 좋은 임차인이
들어올 수도 있고 저도 되게
궁금해요. 그래서 한번 계속
팔로우하면서 봐야 될 것 같습니다.
네. 그래서 오늘은 제가 우리나라에서
가장 비싼 파츠소를 가지고 제가 좀
오늘 설명을 드렸는데 여러분들 뭐
공매랑 경매 나온 것도 한번 좀 계속
좀 지켜보시면 좋을 거 같아요.
그래서 이렇게 생각보다 괜찮은 위치에
있는 건물들이 나올 수도 있거든요.
국가가 소유한 어 그래서 요런 것도
계속 좀 체크해서 보시면 어 오히려
좀 더 기회가 있지 않을까 이렇게
생각을 합니다.네 그래서 오늘 영상은
여기까지 하고요. 다음 시간에 또
뵙도록 하겠습니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]